hello everyone and welcome to the other
match of the semi-finals of the
chessable masters knockouts it's dingley
and versus magnus carlsen we already
know that the first finalist is
pragernanda and now uh one of these two
gentlemen will uh face um uh prague inda
in the final so it's dingle iron versus
magnus carlsen this is game four of
their match uh the first three games
ended in a draw so either either here
we're gonna have a decisive uh game and
the match is over or we're gonna go into
tie breaks like we did in the
match and it's quite incredible if
you've um
if you've been watching uh especially
the the first game of the match that uh
ding again had magnus and the ropes
magnus just you know used his jedi mind
trick power and play that rook to c2
without being realizing bishop to before
was winning uh that's already the second
game uh you know you know basically a
few games that they played that the ding
was completely winning but it's rapid
chess he didn't have enough time to
take
you know
his advantage to to grab a full point uh
but this time uh maybe something else
will happen so let's dive straight into
it it's a really really cool game you
will enjoy it uh ding opens with d4 we
have d5 uh in the game that we discussed
magnus tried the nimzo that bishop to g
for bishop
b4 variation very weird stuff but it
didn't work out all that great for him
uh here so he tries d5 now we have c for
c6 going for the slop defense knight f3
knight to f6 and sorry knight f6 and the
e3
the so-called quiet variation bishop to
g4 and now h3 magnus gives up the bishop
pair early on we have captures captures
and now e6 so he gives up the light
square bishop puts his pawns on light
squares and now he has a dark square
bishop that can go in between those
pawns of course knight to c3 we have
knight beat to d7 and bishop to d3 now
we have bishop to b4
and the both players castle so castles
castles and now rook to d1 aligning the
rook with the queen on d8 we have rook
to e8 and now queen back to e2 ding is
ready to play f4 and he wants to grab
full control over the e5 square
uh queen to e7 by magnus and now bishop
to d2 and there are a couple of moves
that a game that reach this position
usually e5 is played here also d
captures and c4 is a known move but here
we have a6 by magnus and it is now as of
move 12 that we have a completely new
game so ding plays bishop to e1 uh we
have rook a to d8 and now rook a to c1
we have bishop back to d6 and now c5 so
will uh this be a good advancement for
ding or will it uh be something that
magnus can maybe punish later on you can
play b6 try and undermine this if b4
then a5 and so on so we've seen this
many times uh
let's see how it uh how it plays out
with bishop the c7 and finally f4
grabbing control over the e5 square we
have bishop to a5 and this bishop the a5
move is pretty
pretty problematic because here
magnus uh what he wants to do is the
it's a pretty close position we haven't
really traded any pawns yet he wants to
uh trade this bishop for a night and he
says my knight pair will be stronger
than your bishop pair hopefully the
possession will not open up uh the
problem is uh ding just plays knight
captures on d5 and that's that's uh
that's a big problem so magnus will get
to trade his bishop for a night uh
however he will not be able to play b6
because what carlson wanted was let's
say if ding just continues with sound
like a3 he wants to capture here and
after b captures just the best open uh
with b6 this is this is his idea he has
excellent setup for this however after
bishop the a5 ding plays knife captures
on d5 and this is just winning a clean
pawn uh because now the bishop is
hanging on a5 it's undefended and also
the queen is hanging
so e captures on d5 we have to give up
the bishop this way bishop captures an
a5 but now you don't have b6 because
both the bishop and the pawn cover this
square and also your rook is hanging so
rook to c8 by magnus and now rook to c3
now ding wants to put more pressure on
that b file so knight to f8 we have rook
to b3 uh and now comes knight to e6 we
have queen to f3
queen to d7 and now bishop back to e1
now the rule controls the b6 square so
we don't have to keep your bishop on a5
knight to d8 and now rook to b6 now the
other rook will also come to the b file
we have knight to e4
and bishop to c2 now we have f5 and now
rook to d3 so magnus
completely closed the position okay he's
down a pawn but if he gets a draw here
then we go into tie breaks and then he
will try his luck there so here knight
f7 we have rook d to b3 and now we have
rook to c7 where we have to defend the
b7 pawn that's the base of our pawn
chain king to f1
and here i think after uh when this king
to f1 was played as this is what i
decided to use for the thumbnail here
after king to f1 was played i think
magnus realized that trouble is is very
near
because ding will now hide his king all
the way to the queen side and then he
will start pushing opening up the
position and uh well trying uh trying to
exploit the two weaknesses one being the
weak b7 pawn the other one at the attack
on the king side if it opens up then
everything just comes alive he still has
the bishop pair so one thing magnus
doesn't want to allow is for the
position to open up
and here magnus has to has to create
some sort of a blockade to try and
prevent this so he starts with queen to
c8
and we have king day ding just continues
uh moving the king all the way to the
queen side we have knight to h8 king to
d1 now comes knight to g6 and king to c1
we have knight to f8 uh bishop the f a5
uh um preparing to move the rook and uh
open up a discovery here so rook to f7
uh and now comes king to b1 so it's
another problem as both the king both
the queen and the rook are guarding the
b7 pawn uh h6 and now pawn to a3 so the
king is coming all the way to a2 we have
knight to h7 king to a2 and now knight h
to f6 so this is what magnus
was able to do in the meantime while
ding was bringing his king all the way
to the a2 square he has this very nice
setup with the knight on e4 the knight
on f6 he has a very nice control over
the g4 square so g4 will not be a
problem for him uh and uh well he still
he he he now has to wait and see what
the ding will do ding plays bishop to e1
uh and now magnus
doesn't want to wait uh he strikes with
the g5 himself and it's uh it's a really
really uh elegant solution because if
ding opens up uh then still the position
is is kind of close the king can now
come all the way to g6 and you can
double up on the h file it doesn't seem
like dean will be able to push on the
king's side so instead we have bishop to
d1 and now okay magnus advances the pawn
even further we have g4
h captures f captures and queen to f1
now uh we have h5 g3 would have been
more precise but again this is rapid
chess it's hard to calculate everything
out
we have h5 and now queen to h1 putting
pressure on that h5 pawn but okay for
the moment it is defended by this knight
king to g7 now comes the bishop to h4
and now
we want to put our bishop on c2 grab
hold of this diagonal
and it will be
somewhat difficult for for magnus to
keep
everything in check because the h5 pawn
will just be too weak so here he tries
knight to g8 but now just to push up the
c2 and here comes knight the d2
attacking ding's knight and rook on b3
but now the position is completely
winning for ding uh but you have to play
a very very uh precise uh move so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this idea for ding while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is bishop
the g5 there are uh other moves that uh
will um uh retain a winning position for
white but the bishop the g5 is just the
most the most uh forcing now we are
gonna capture on h5 and there is nothing
you can do about this as black so here
okay we grab the rook knight captures on
b3 rook captures and now knight to f6 we
guard the h5 pawn but not just bishop
captures on f6 we have rook captures and
uh sorry rook captures and queen
captures on h5 now preparing queen to h7
check so rook to h8 by magnus and now
queen to e5 so if dink cannot
finish this game
by some sort of a checkmate or by
winning a lot of material uh magnus
might even win this because he is up
material for the moment so king to f7 he
unpins now comes e4 ding wants to open
up the position carlson's king is in the
center of the board we have to uh open
up
lines of attack for our bishop and rook
so d captures on e4 we have bishop
captures rook to e8 now and the queen to
h5 with check we have king e7 and now d5
there is no time to
wait we have to continue pushing king d8
magnus is hoping to hide the king all
the way to the queen side much like ding
did but
erding will not allow it queen g5 now
attacks the rook rook to f8 defends the
rook and now rook to d3 threatening all
sorts of nasty discoveries and there's
no good way to hide the king if you try
to hide the king then just queen e5
check and you're getting checkmated you
cannot go anywhere you have to go back
to the d file then the captures on c6
and you are out of squares you have to
start giving up material and well not
that one and that's going to be it so
instead after rook to the three queen
the c7 by magnus trying to hide the king
this way
but not the characters and c6 would
check king the c8 and queen captures on
g4 with check ding just gobbles up
material and in the process forces the
king all the way to b8 and now comes
rook to d7 and now it uh becomes
apparent that there is really no way to
to continue this game for for magnus he
tries rook captures on f4 hoping to get
a queen trade in but of course ding
doesn't go for it he just placed queen
to g7 and he was in this position on
move 56 that magnus carlsen resigned the
game and what an incredible victory for
dingler and not only in game four of
their match but also in the entire match
as this uh this ends the match and so we
will have uh in the finals pragernanda
versus ding liran and we'll see will
will prague will be able to take it all
the way or is being uh just uh on a
completely uh completely different level
as now he is also uh in the candidates
tournament he has been studying very
hard and he is just one of those players
that kind of belongs uh in the 2800 club
or you know pretty much uh uh the entire
time uh but uh you know it it's been a
hard time for him he he couldn't play
then he he qualified but he couldn't get
to the candidates it was pretty pretty
crazy for him but now finally we will
see him there and you know great things
are expected from him and of course
everyone knows magnus said he will only
play alireza if he wins the candidates
but i don't see him declining a
challenge from ding especially with the
ding giving him such a such a hard time
with pretty much every game they play uh
so yeah here you resign because uh if
you okay uh you you cannot um you can't
really trade queens if you go rook rook
f7 we're just going to trade like this
rook capture sun on c7 and once you
trade you're going to be down a full
bishop so that's out of the question and
if you try after let's say queen g7 you
try something like queen c8 to try and
uh hold on maybe
if rook captures you can get some queen
to e6 check in maybe rook f1 does
something and doesn't really do anything
rook b7 check king to a8 and now just
bishop d5 we prevent queen e6 and there
is no no playing this uh uh if if we
want we can even uh you know uh make
support of this position let's say goes
after bishop uh rook c7 we attack the
queen and once queen b8 is played now we
can even sacrifice the rook rook to a7
check queen captures now we deliver this
check we force the rook to capture and
uh
move away from the defense of the rook
and f8 and after looking out for sunday
fight we play king queen captures an f8
and of course everything is just winning
but also let's see just c8 queen and
that's it this is not checkmate the b6
square has been taken from the black
king uh that's it uh so many many uh
moves are winning here of course this is
just the one i decided to show you as
it's the nicest one i believe so yeah on
move 56 magnus resigned and big
congratulations to ding for beating
magnus and reaching the finals against
pragernanda
so yeah that's the game i hope you hope
you guys enjoyed it really a wild one
and uh well i just
the thing i enjoyed most about this game
was most definitely the king march
starting with king to f1 uh this is just
i mean beautiful stuff like there's the
weakness but we need another one so
we're just going to hide the king all
the way here and then open up the
position
didn't even have to wait magnus open the
position himself as uh it was a good
idea uh is just that ding's position was
much much better but yeah uh
i really really hope you guys enjoyed
this one uh i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to salvatore cano and i
would like to thank robert key for mark
manner and nagarjuna pongotti and both
swing cat for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals uh
of this wonderful event uh until it
finishes uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day